apparently the whole bunch of brothers
been missing in this summer what school
are you my skin is man I love uh the TSA
worker in this film can we please get a
TV spin-off can we get on my iPhone
movie so slow down well he's already on
the Carmichael show so if you miss
seeing him every time I'm out in LA I
see him on the posters yeah oh yeah row
row row but I wouldn't mind like a full
just little rel at the TSA spin-off uh
throw sit in there even though Sid was
very stubborn after the dog though the
net so Sammy will get the best of it
yeah um I would definitely do that right
I love him yeah sorry man it really is a
conversation starter about something
that's actually still happening in post
racism so I wanted to know what the
reaction has been you know for you guys
since the film has been released
very long emails yeah because people
really very passionate by it and I go I
want what this means this like this to
me this is mean that to me this I've
been that a little bit it's just so
lovely to like people that are engaging
with it and like that and then fully
invested and then watching it again yeah
I have a cousin he finally just went
finished going through immigration and
so she's had like a really complicated
relationship with the u.s. even though
she was trying so hard to become a
citizen and she emailed me in the
separate line was yay get out and white
people and it was like three pages long
and I still haven't it's like genius and
I will it's brilliant and I just I want
to be able to respond in kind if it's
taking me oh I love that
[Music]